German Chancellor Olaf Schultz is
preparing to testify for a second time
in an investigation into a scandal that
has undermined trust in Germany's
financial institutions and government
oversight companies and investors
defrauded the German state of billions
of Euros in the so-called comex stance
Scandal the Scandal came to light five
years ago when Schultz was mayor of
Hamburg investigators want to know about
meetings he had with one of the banks
involved back then but so far he says he
doesn't remember
what did he know when
four years now all of Schultz has not
been able to shake off Germany's biggest
ever tax scandal when he was mayor of
Hamburg he met with officials from
Warwick Bank
it owed the city of Hamburg 47 million
euros for claiming refunds on taxes it
never paid
after Schultz met the bank's officials
Hamburg authorities dropped their
demands
at first Schultz falsely claimed those
meetings didn't happen
but was proven wrong
now he says he cannot remember what was
discussed and has been Keen to stress
there is no connection between his
meetings and the city backing down this
growing mistrust in his version of
events
it is unlikely that he cannot remember
anything from this meetings during those
meetings or phone calls it was about
nearly 50 million euro for his City in
tax revenue the whole aspect of working
here with the salami tactic of just
admitting what he has to admit and once
more has been proven he will admit more
obviously makes it that much more
doubtful that there is just no memory at
all so far prosecutors do not see any
breach of the law the Scandal is hitting
the headlines again now because of
former Hamburg MP from Schultz's party
had stashed away 200 000 Euros in cash
and that MP's District had received
money from Warwick bank before as yet
nobody knows where the cash came from
and Schultz has denied any knowledge
what do you know about the cash in the
former MP safe deposit box
nothing
next question where do you think it came
from
no idea I guess you know better than I
do whatever emerges from today's hearing
it surely won't be the end of the story
let's bring in our political
correspondent Nina haza here Nina
Chancellor of Schultz is due to testify
in this tax Scandal today is he expected
to shed any light on it
well I wouldn't expect that to happen
Terry because
um all I've showed the strategy is to
stick to what he's been saying all along
he can't remember the details of the
conversations with the officials from
the bank and you have to keep in mind
that some 50 Witnesses have been heard
so far in by this committee and there is
no evidence so far even after all these
statements that he knows more than he is
saying or that he even played an active
role so I don't think that we're going
to be learning much
um new information today
now Schultz himself is not the target of
this investigation it must be said he's
a appearing only as a witness relating
to his former role as mayor of Hamburg
so why is this still a potential danger
for him Nina
yes that is actually this is the big
question that we have to address look
Terry this Scandal is about a very
complicated story I doubt that many
Germans even understand just how this
tax fraud model Works they don't know
enough they don't know who could have
stopped it where it when and it is
correct all I've said is not the target
of Investigation himself he is a witness
regarding something that happened while
he was mayor in Hamburg but keep in mind
comex didn't just happen in Hamburg it
went on for years German taxpayers lost
billions of euros and still to this day
no politician in Germany has assumed
responsibility for this biggest tax
fraud in German history so now pressure
is mounting on Olaf so it's because of
course he's no longer just the mayor of
Hamburg he is now the German Chancellor
and of course trust confidence
transparency they're all vital Assets in
that position and some members of the
opposition are saying that it's his
handling of this story now that is the
big Scandal that he says he can't
remember meeting those officials he
hasn't taken more initiative in actively
trying to shed light on this story and
that all of that is not worthy of his
position as Chancellor so some are even
demanding he resign but whatever happens
today this story will continue to haunt
him unless he takes an active step in
trying to shed some light
Nina thank you very much our political
correspondent Nina haza there